انا اتحدث الى هذا الفريق من الشبان
السوريين جاؤوا للتو من وسط الركام هم
يعملون منذ بدايه الازمه قاموا باخراج
اشخاص على قيد الحياه لهم تجارب سريعه
واسمحي لي ان استفسر منهم عن بعض الامور
تحياتي انت الاختيار ان نتحدث اليك اولا
يعطيكم الف عافيه على جهودكم
كم جثه على قيد كم شخص على قيد الحياه
اخرجتوه وكم جثه لمتوفي تقريبا الله
يعافيك نشكر على قناه الحدث العربيه
العربيه القناه الحدث العربيه نشكره على
وصول المناطق نحن شبان من قريه اسمها
شحروره من باير بوجر وبعد هذه الزلزال
سبحان الله هذا طوعتم للمساعده هذه
الاشخاص تحت الركام الحمد لله تم بعون
الله سبحانه وتعالى اخراج ما بين 10 او 15
شخص عقيد الحقيد الحياه وما يقارب شيء 20
شخص متوفين
حتى نقدر نوصل لعندهم بعد ما وصلنا الاخت
طلعت سليم ما فيها شيء
والرجل علق اجره تحت الاركان بين الباطون
تمينا اربعه او ثلاث ساعات كمان بس
التحرير رجله سبحان الله اخر شيء فقد
الامل وقال اقطع اجري يا الله اي والله
قال اقطع عشري واخرجني قلت له لا يا اخي
ان شاء الله انا بدي احاول لحتى احرر
سبحان الله والحمد لله الله عز وجل فتح
علينا
وتخلى عن رجله حتى يلحظه اي والله الرجله
حتى يخرج بدنه الحمد لله الله عز وجل
وحررنا الموقف الاخر لانه ما عندناش وقت
كثير اسف بس يعني موقف في الاخر سبحان
الله اخرجنا طفل
في عمر 11 سنه
قبل ما نوصل لعندو سالناه مين معك قال
خالتي وابن خالتي قلنا له مين متوفي قال
بس لاخرج ان شاء الله انا استغربت من ذكاء
الطفل قال بس ان شاء الله اخرج نتكلم بعد
ما خرج قال خالتي عايشه وابنها متوفي
سبحان الله جوا قال هذا الحكي مشان ما
يسمع خالتو ما بتعرفي عشان ما يجرحها يعني
عشان عشان ما يجرحها تحت الركام